je suis la france oubliez dit patricia
qu'à l'aménagement du territoire donc
possible pour redonner du dynamisme à
ses communes abandonné car on a vu à
l'occasion de la crise sanitaire les
français aiment vivre à la campagne d'où
notre question ce soir abandon des
territoires quelle réponse des
politiques on attend vos réactions sur
notre compte télégramme et place à notre
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler et 10
puijalon président du mouvement de la
ruralité bonsoir haredi appui jalons
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes en
liaison
skype avec nos alexis poulain sur ce
plateau éditorialistes rt france bonsoir
et merci et puis patricia marc ce biais
on vous retrouve un maire de dons rouge
en ile et vilaine c'est vous convient
donc va percevoir dans ce reportage
merci d'être là je me retourne vers vous
pour commencer puisque depuis le
tournage de ce reportage il ya quelques
jours vous avez adhéré au parti
reconquête on se devait donc d'être
transparent vis-à-vis de nos
téléspectateurs
qu'est ce que vous trouvez chez eric
zemmour qu'il n'y a pas chez les autres
candidats notamment marie le pen qui a
souvent été présentée comme la
championne des territoires un patricia
baars e lle
les goûters mois eric zemmour je le
connais depuis peu et je trouve en lui
une ceinture une sincérité qui se dégage
est un de l'espoir pour le pays
dans ses propositions
sincérité espoir mais pour justement le
sujet qui nous anime ces territoires que
vous avez montré abandonné 1 il ne vous
reste quasiment quinqua commerce que
vous essayez défendre c'est lui qui
semble répondre en tout cas selon vous
le plus à vos attentes
et oui donc des fonds là la vitalité de
notre dernier commerce est pour nous
important mais il ya aussi
parce que c'est un ici c'est
l'arrivée de des moyens de
télécommunication fiable on est on a
d'autres très très mauvaise connexion au
niveau
téléphonie et internet et ça c'est
indispensable pour pouvoir accueillir
que ce soit un commerçant que ce soit de
nouveaux habitants et ça c'est une
lacune qui nous empêchent de sortir
notre épingle du jeu qui traînent les
travaux ont été réalisés il ya deux ans
et aujourd'hui on est toujours en
attente de
fêtes de commercialisation et en abuse
battre je ne voit toujours rien venir et
ça c'est un des piliers indispensables
aujourd'hui pour tenir un commerce et
donc je j'ai lancé des appels aux
politiques et j'attends
j'espère prochainement décide favorable
à l'aboutissement de sept de ses
réponses politiques et 10 puis j'ai
lancé très important ce que vient de
nous dire patricia marc saulnier parce
que c'est quelque chose dont on parle
extrêmement peu finalement les liaisons
téléphoniques alors où on est sur
internet toute la journée dans le métro
parisien ça semble totalement oublié
effectivement ce type de sujet je crois
que les parents entendus dans la bouche
d'un seul candidat vous les avez
peut-être entendu hier en parler tout
simplement avoir une bonne connexion
avoir le téléphone correctement la
connexion internet ça paraît la base
aujourd'hui et ça l'est pas vraiment
dans les campagnes
disons que dans mon petit court
discours d'introduction pour l'ensemble
des candidats qui sont venus répondre
aux demandes et ruralité évidemment que
j'ai abordé non seulement l'internet
mais la fibre jusqu à l'habitat isolé
indispensable pour faire venir des
néoruraux mais j'ai quand même rappeler
que la téléphonie mobile n'est pas c'est
pas un apport dans notre pays donc
c'était parfois extrêmement compliqué
pour nos concitoyens de penser comme un
énorme trafic alors que même leurs
téléphones portables ne passent pas donc
voilà il y avait vraiment besoin de
booster un peu les candidats
pour savoir quel était l'enjeu le sud
s'il était prêt à investir parce que
c'est faisable on a quantifié à peu près
5 milliards pour m la leche fibre chez
tous les habitants ça c'est du domaine
de l'indispensable mais quand on parle
de la fille ou du téléphone pour là
aussi des mois sncf les petites et link
enfin qu'avec abandonné les voies
routières aujourd'hui c'est ce que je
disais un peu donc je suis très très
content de voir madame la mairesse et je
le connais très bien ces problématiques
des territoires ruraux ce que je disais
à eric zemmour est généralement tous les
candidats et suivant ce qu'il propose et
c'est que effectivement si on veut
donner la possibilité de faire des
naissances en milieu rural il faut
commencer par d'abord ce mais le bond de
keroman c'est à dire mettre les
conditions d'acceptabilité d'une vie
sociale et donc former des services
publics former des médecins formés des
hôpitaux des cliniques et ensuite
effectivement le braun des naissances
qui vont trouver de quoi travailler et
avoir une vie sociale dans nos
territoires ruraux mais aujourd'hui
quand il fallait dans une métropole pour
travailler et qu'il faut passer une
heure et demie dans les transports et sa
voiture parce qu a pas de transports en
commun et que les cours du carburant
bien nous reposer là dessus plus les
coûts de garde je vous garantis
qu'aujourd'hui la vie du milieu rural
est quelque chose d'extrêmement
compliqué ça ne m'étonne pas que tout
ferme donc voilà il faut commencer par
le bout et en même temps et victimes
mais on sait bien que pour proposer un
peu d'argent pour construire leur
famille à voir l' envie de faire des
enfants parce que on se dit que pour
assumer pleinement son rôle de parent
faire des enfants et aussi parfois
déménager parce qu'on l'a vu à
l'occasion voilà de cette crise
sanitaire il ya un sacré paquet de paris
les siens qui ont eu envie d'habiter à
la campagne
d'ailleurs regardez
47% des français souhaitent aller
habiter en ruralité ou à tout le moins
bien débile moyenne chercheurs tirent
des métropoles exactement je vais vous
le montrez d'ailleurs ce sondage ifop
travailler et vivre à la campagne 46%
des français vivre et travailler en
ville ça n'a pas beaucoup de succès 20%
alexis poulain dans le même temps c'est
compliqué télétravailler à la campagne
sans internet c'est vrai que c'est un
constat dont on parle quand même très
peu c'est de mon âge sont assez
édifiants et quand même poignant quand
on aime la france et ses territoires
mais évidemment non mais cette campagne
présidentielle elle est tragique parce
qu'en fait on découvre la réalité d'un
pays qui est masquée par les techno qui
sont au pouvoir depuis des années soit
emmanuel macron ceux qui l'ont précédé
il ya des discours magnifique alors là
on a un nouveau un plan france relance
france 2030 c'est magnifique sur le
papier la réalité c'est que en france on
ne capte pas en téléphonie mobile on n'a
pas la fibre on a des ddp des pays
enclavés des territoires totalement
enclavé alors de temps en temps jean
castex pour un avion à ça coûte très
cher pour aller ouvrir une autoroute ou
un truc comme ça à dire hawaï on a fait
un petit truc la réalité c'est qu'on
découvre l'état de notre pays c'est un
pays en déshérence c'est un p abandonné
c'est un pays qui nous a menti
finalement satisfaire alexis non c'est
ce que je dis
il faut reprendre le pouvoir aux
énarques et au cabinet de conseil ils ne
font que mentir ils ne font que
manipuler des chiffres la réalité du
terrain c'est regarder pourquoi on n'est
pas foutu de mettre la fibre parce que
grâce à l'union européenne ou plutôt à
cause on ne peut plus faire de champions
nationaux on ne peut pas étatisée ce
genre de service est un service public
non mais pourquoi ça ne marche plus vous
avez encore un petit reste de service
public qui est edf qui en cas de tempête
ou en cas de gros grains arrive à
remettre l'électricité assez rapidement
mais quand sera sera privatisée vous
n'aurez plus même pas ce service là la
voirie c'est pareil on va on va
décentraliser on va voir le problème que
ça fait sur l'eau on a lutté pour
remettre l'eau quand même dans les
communes et éviter des dérives avec la
privatisation mais sur les télécoms
enfin aujourd'hui avec ce secret 17 ce
plan de numériser tout la société c'est
impossible en france actuellement
effectivement on peut pas se rendre on
peut pas habiter et lé travail et si on
n'a pas une connexion internet digne de
ce nom si on n'a pas non plus une gare
pas très loin de chez soi si on n'a pas
de service public et 7 mm cette maison
commune qui a été construite maison de
la république je sais pas comment ils
appellent ça
mais la réalité c'est que les villes
moyennes les villages alors qu'ils
pourraient se remplir alors que c'est un
cadre de vie agréable et bien c'est
beaucoup de barrières sont mis à
l'entrée finalement parce que on a des
seins et à centraliser qui vit sur un
songe en réalité et qui ne connaît pas
la réalité de ce pays on va aller
regarder les réactions internet à la
question de savoir donc quelles réponses
des politiques mais l'âge 78 qui lui ce
n'est pas normal de ne plus avoir un
minimum de services publics et de toubib
dans nos campagnes des vidéos qui nous
dit dans mon village pas de poses plus
de médecins il faut prendre la voiture
pour aller dans un grand centre
commercial à 10km la crise des gilet
jaune n'a t'elle pas servi de leçon non
clairement et 10 puijalon sa crise dg
les journaux me rappelle quand même un l
et on s'en souvient devant l'arc de
triomphe mais enfin on se souvient
peut-être moins qu'elle a pris naissance
justement sur les ronds-points au fin
fond de la france elle a pris naissance
sur l'augmentation du coût du carburant
et comme le djembé dan demers et c'est
aujourd'hui la dépense notre première
pour les ruraux parce qu'on se serre la
voiture au quotidien et porto où étaient
de plus en plus loin dire que quand
l'école n'est plus dans la commune il
fallait dans la commune à côté quand le
médecin est à 20 km quand tous les
services publics sont à plus de 20 ou 30
km vous prenez votre voiture au
quotidien plus le travail donc cette
augmentation dans de légion en mémoire
le plein à 50 euros aujourd'hui à 80
euros imaginez un peu le coup que ça
fait sur des budgets et des salaires qui
sont capables des petits salaires en
milieu rural sur les passions ainsi
l'air à salers alignés sur les parisiens
donc abandonné là le sujet on n'a pas
tiré les leçons et gilet jaune il ya une
facture mais une fracture sociétale mais
aujourd'hui la colère est en train de
remonter et on est en attente
aujourd'hui de vrais gestes des
candidats à la présidentielle pour venir
voir ce qui s'y passe mais on est
dépouillée de tous par contre on paye
les mêmes sympômes tiers que nous on
paye le prix fort et on est supprimée de
tous les avantages je ne parle pas je
sais pas si on est maire nan mais
j'parle pas même pas de nous parler de
la voiture électrique alors je fais
douce émulsionner si on d'essence et de
carburants qui main parce que le tarif
d'une station est une petite station de
campagne et tarifs encore au dessus de
ce qu'ils peuvent aller dans les grandes
surfaces et comme tel il écrit que c'est
même plus passer ni d'y penser on nous
met juste seoul viennent pour nous un
paquet un peu plus comme ça car en plus
c'est bien immobilier puisque quelques
quelques contraintes sanitaires et on
vient embêter un peu madame le maire ou
monsieur le maire pour guirec position
et d'argent prenez dans des éoliennes et
du photovoltaïque d'augurer vous aurez
des l'argent n'est ce pas voilà le grand
sujet aujourd'hui on méprise les élus on
essaie de les acheter alors qu'ils sont
là pour construire l'avenir de leurs
concitoyens patricia marsollier aucun
candidat aucun politique en tout cas
selon vous depuis ces dernières années
de s'intéresser sérieusement justement
aux campagnes et que c'était peut-être
pendant les campagnes présidentielles le
dernier cd qui pour vous
écoutez moi ça fait cinq ans que je suis
élu je suis maire ça fait cinq ans que
j'ai l'impression que
les dotations baisse et on est obligé de
faire avec et nos dépenses d'entretien
ne serait-ce que la voir il n'y échappe
pas et ça c'est au détriment de
peut-être
d'aménager des logements pour accueillir
les nouvelles familles voix voilà donc
c'est hollande c'est ce sont des choses
que nos politiques n'ont pas forcément
conscience dans de petites villes dans
nos petits villages quoi alexis blanc on
parlait de la crise d'aidé gilet jaune
on n'a pas tiré les enseignements
pourtant se souvient quand jean castex
est arrivé ce poste région région
territoire ça a été prononcé je ne sais
combien de temps après l'assemblée
nationale c'était quand même le lan
10/100 ce premier ministre non mais
l'ambition l'ambition affichée quand je
vous parle de de songes de mensonges de
la façon dont on présente les choses
jean castex connaît les territoires
parce qu'il fait des aller retour en jet
de temps en temps pour aller ouvrir un
nouveau centre commercial où rencontrer
des élus pour faire de la com c'est de
la communication ces énarques non pas le
pays dans le ventre et n'ont pas la
connaissance non plus du pays alors
peut-être quelques réserves quant à elle
c'est du sud ouest certes certes mais ça
fait longtemps que au delà du sud ouest
c'est comme emmanuel macron qui nous
vend la mongie alors il va la montagne
chez sa grand mère c'est formidable a
une connaissance du terrain et puis le
touquet formidable aussi mais la réalité
c'est que quand vous traversez ce pays
on a affaire à des touristes la classe
politique majoritairement sont des
touristes qui ne connaissent pas ce pays
de temps en temps d'ailleurs dès qu'ils
sont qui passe en campagne ils vont à la
rencontre des français va nous redonner
la parole avec si pardon je faisais un
petit coupé le sifflet mais je voulais
quand même vous faire écouter emmanuel
macron parce qu'ils seraient pas du tout
d'accord avec vous est sûrement alors on
va l'écouter pour lui donner quand même
la réponse
est donc la nation a choisi de
réinvestir partout sur ces territoires
en donnant des outils adaptés aux élus
mais aussi aux associations qui les
accompagnent dans leurs actions et à
l'ensemble des fonctionnaires les moyens
de créer de nouvelles de nouveaux types
d'activités et au fond j'appellerais ça
moi l'agenda de confiance c'est à dire
sur nos territoires on doit pouvoir
justement redéployer des projets aller
de l'avant et réussir justement à
réadapter recrée de centre-ville le
centre bourg rouvrir des services avec
ses différents agenda 10 puis j'ai
renvoyé que vous oublie pas emmanuel
macron vous qui demandait un grand
ministère de la ruralité
je suis dépité quand je vois ce décalage
entre un
temps un président qui va nous raconter
des balivernes alors que sur le terrain
comme le dit me lemaire au quotidien
c'est la galère parce qu'ils absolument
rien que tout ferme qu'on ait abandonné
de tous et que l'administration
l'administration centrale qu'elle soit
parisienne des grandes métropoles n'a
que du mépris pour les élus ruraux et
pour tous les héros c'est c'est une
surcharge administrative c'est une perte
de temps on sait plus comment pouvoir
arriver ne serait-ce qu'un même rétablir
une habitat ou pouvoir construire
quelque chose même un cabanon pour des
outils des professionnels il sait
devient la croix et la bannière il ya
tout un empilage administratif qui n'est
que contre elle pour les ruraux on ne
peut plus rien faire en ruralité j'ai
des maires tous les jours qu'ils me
disent mais on nous parle de faire venir
des gens la bile de la ville vers un
terrain pas mais comment vous fait
aujourd'hui on peut même plus des
poussins permis de construire
l'artificialisation des sols c'est venu
par les gens de la de la grande ville de
la métropole les présidents de région
ils ont des grandes visions mais c'est
toujours la même chose moi j'ai connu la
création des pays toute la surcharge
maintenant ce sont les les groupements
de communes mais tout ça si c'est
inefficace ce n'est juste que donner du
pouvoir encore plus du pouvoir ce qui
est le plus gros il ya un capitalisant
tous les bénéfices ceux des plus grands
habitant ce délai des constructions et
on laisse toujours l'abandon il n'y a
pas de partage dans ce dans ce pays il
n'ya pas de partage équitable pour avoir
une construction une équité sursaut tous
les territoires parce que sky jusque à
courir jusqu'aux petites communes parce
que là on aurait quelque chose
d'intelligent l'agression depuis des
pays j'ai passé moins de temps tant que
juste simple citoyen je croyais qu'on
allait faire quelque chose et
intelligent pour emmener le travail
jusqu au plus près du citoyen du fin
fond de la de la commune ou de la
circonscription pas du tout on a eu
encore des grands des grands élus qui
voulaient tout comme les monarques
régenter capitalisées et donc on a fait
n'importe quoi et puis là il est arrivé
maintenant que les petites communes ça
coûte cher mais arrêter il faut forer
car les jeudis à la bêtise forestiers
des bêtises et des petites communes ça
ne coûte rien au contraire faut les
aider ce sont des gens dévoués qui
servent de racine sur le territoire mais
non vous supprimez tout ça et on est en
train de faire tout et n'importe quoi
que lille métropole dès qu'on arrive
avec un tgv qu'est ce qu'on fait on
amène de l'emploi dans l'attendu trop
paul on est en train de tout construire
de métropole et on a encore en train de
vider tout ce qui est les territoires
ruraux c'est une aberration moi je
voulais ajouter quelque chose c'est que
la france est capable d'effacer la dette
de pays africains d'être à milliards
d'euros mais il ya des villages qui
meurent de la dette je pensais à
marvejols où tous les laits pas de
commerces sont fermés à cause justement
de la dette des petites communes
pourquoi l'état n'est pas capable
d'effacer la dette de ces communes est
de dire on repart à zéro et justement on
va vous aider pour re dynamiser les
territoires ces discours vides de dire
on va donner plus de pouvoir on va faire
encore du millefeuille administratif ça
ne sert plus à rien il faut du côté sale
et aujourd'hui promesses pour le coup du
président macron de réduire
il est question d'argent là il est
question d'argent de moyens exactement
comme pour l'hôpital
patrice à patricia marseillais cette
histoire effectivement de lourdeurs
administratives la voulait maire vous
êtes vraiment en plein dedans les mains
dans le cambouis si j'ose dire
tout à fait est là du coup depuis le 1er
janvier on est censé contrer dans une
phase de dématérialisation on est
incapable d'assumer compte tenu que
jeudi on est on est pas du tout au top
par rapport
aux connexions c'est
infernal
eddie puyjalon comment justement vous
allez l'aborder cette campagne
présidentielle avec une forme de
résignation ou ou quand même une forme
d'espoir tout de même sont
nécessairement vous demande pas de
prendre parti pour tel ou tel candidat
mais ce qu'il ya du nouveau sous le
soleil pour vous si vous voulez nous on
à paris enfin le fait venir tous les
candidats qui souhaitait venir
s'exprimer chaque sujet a proposé de 30
points je note et qu'on a eu que des
candidats de droite c'est bien dommage
je ne vais respirer pendant le temps où
l'ex péter ça
donc je pense à part peut-être fabien
roussel qui au dernier moment voulaient
se faire remplacer qu'on voulait quand
même les candidats internes hausse comme
j'ai dit je pense que la gauche est très
mal à l'aise aujourd'hui sur des sujets
sociétaux
notamment sur la partie élevage
animalistes etc ils sont passés très
proche de l'écologie punitive par leur
proximité avec les verts et je trouve
que c'est dommage il aurait dû sortir de
ce carcan mandat pour venir nous dire
leur vision de la ruralité leur vision
de la consommation de vin moi quand je
reviens dessus l'élevage français quand
je parle de l'éolien quand je parle de
la consommation se fait bien puisque
j'ai une vision de la france mais je
pense le démontrer le débat démocratique
aurait dû écrire et tout ça bon voilà
marine le pen n'a pas souhaité venir a
priori parce qu'elles étaient occupées
sur la langue française mais là aussi
les racines qui font que c'est dommage
maintenant ceux qui étaient là ce sont
bien exprimés non leur donner quelques
pistes de réflexion sur tous les sujets
dans les sujets des petites communes
rurales je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
attaquer la métropolisation allait
passer par le développement des villes
moyennes pour irriguer tout le
territoire notamment un travail un
service il faut essayer aujourd'hui
toute cette france rurale pour que
demain les néo ruraux qui veulent
arriver aux familles qui veut construire
on en connaît beaucoup parce qu'il ya
des jeunes qui veulent monter les stores
club avec sur l'électronique messi
comment voyez vous mettre une start up
basée sur l'électronique si vous n'avez
pas la fille n'est pas de réseau ni même
pas le téléphone en forêt
merci en tout cas merci à tous les trois
d'avoir été là merci madame un merci à
vous également eddie puyjalon et alexis
boulin et c'est la fin de set